you went vegan and you you've you said
you've adopted the whole lifestyle which
includes
yeah how you talk about being vegan i
pronounced some vegan words better than
basically anyone on the planet conan
like what like quinoa like it's spelled
quinoa
a lot of people say quinoa that's not it
but then they say quinoa as if it's like
french
like they'll say like quinoa it's no
it's it's an incan superfood
from peru that's where it's from you've
got to say it
with kind of an old world kind of uh a
wisdom kind of almost a little bit
native american like quinoa
[Laughter]
also acai
is frequently mispronounced it's not
it's spelled kind of like acai
yeah yeah yeah that's what i sometimes
it's brazilian you have to move your
hips a little bit when you say it
you just say a sight just like that just
a little just give them a little touch
amazing
we can't see because of this you don't
know what's going on down here which
which trust me is fine uh we get to use
our imagination
yeah but acai yeah that's amazing you've
got the whole thing down pat
yeah i'm very proud of you thanks conan
uh i didn't really mean it uh
anderson you went to iceland recently
and you tried some exotic food speaking
of foods yeah i
um was uh i took a trip to iceland i
love iceland it's so beautiful but
they have this weird uh mean-spirited
trick in iceland where
there's this fermented shark that they
bury underground for a year i'm not
making this up it's called
carl and the thing they love to do to
tourists is say
they'll say try our shark try a
fermented shark like
don't smell it just put it in your mouth
just eat it and i ate it and conan
this was truly the most disgusting
horrible sensation i've ever had in my
life i will never
forget it it's like someone took it's
like you vomited
into a little piece of tire and then
and then ate that it's like melted
rubber and cooked
vomit okay that's and i will never
forget why are you trying to make us
as unhappy as you were having food but
they're such
sweet people but that's a sport in
iceland to get you to eat this and then
they laugh at you you eat it and you
you meet this horrible you make a facial
expression that's
part way between like anger and nausea
what does that look like anger and
nausea well do you
start with anger start with the nausea
and then anger
try it try it okay nausea
and then anger
this is what i do when i'm angry that's
what they can do yeah that's the most i
can much
just sit no one does that anymore yeah
you tweeted that you do an impression a
very specific impression
of a field goal kicker who just
missed a field goal yeah and you tweeted
that but i don't know if you can really
do
it oh i can do it you want to see this i
want to see this is a field
okay lynn you want to see this all right
i'm not going to do the kick very well
but basically all right
this is he misses it okay bang
someone pats him on the shoulder he's
like
it's a combination
that didn't get many laughs okay and i'm
sorry but i just want to say it's a
combination of like
he doesn't feel as bad as he's showing
do you understand yes
like it's all for show yeah he knows
he's going to miss a certain
amount of feel he's going to miss a
percentage that that self-flagellation
as he walks to the bench
it's very calculated i find yeah yeah
but he's got to put it on that show of
humility how long have you been working
on this impression
i just did it
actually i tried it backstage behind the
curtain and it didn't go well there
either so